وجود الجماعات المعارضه على الحدود
العراقيه الايرانيه كان مصدر قلق واحراج
بالنسبه للحكومه
العراقيه اعتقد ان التعاون بين الحكومه
الايرانيه والحكومه العراقيه حاليه كان
جيدا جدا بالمقارنه مع الحقبات السابقه
تطورت الامور بشكل دراماتيكي وسريع من
خلال يعني نزوح العديد من اللاجئين
الايرانيين الى المعارضين الى الحدود
العراقيه ودخولهم في معسكرات نصبت قريبه
على الحدود الايرانيه العراقيه وتحولت هذه
المعسكرات الى عمليات تدريب ويعني تجنيد
لعناصر للقيام بعمليات ضد ايران
اعتقد ان المسؤولين الايرانيين يتحدثون
ويقولون انه اذا ما لم يتم الالتزام بهذا
الم
سوف تتخذ ايران التدابير المناسبه
الايرانيه السابقه القصف الايراني القصف
الايراني
ل معسكرات
المجموعات المعارضه وايران ايضا تحدثت عن
علاقه بين هذه المجموعات
واسرائيل
اعتقد الان بالنسبه الى الاصرار الايراني
والتعاون مع الحكومه
العراقيه السبب وراء ذلك هو ذكرى
المظاهرات التي حصلت في سبتمبر في البلاد
ولذلك تطلب ايران من الحكومه العراقيه ان
تحترم هذه المهله الزمنيه وان تتا اكد من
احراز تقدم بحلول ايلول سبتمبر ب هذه
اللجان المشتركه تعمل بشكل ايجابي وهي
تقول بان ما تم من اجراءات فعلا هو تنفيذ
لاتفاقيه او مذكره التفاهم بين ايران
والعراق هناك مذكرات قبض تجري في المحاكم
العراقيه وبالتعاون مع الجهات المختصه
القضائيه من اجل يعني تنفيذ البند الثاني
من القاء القبض على هؤلاء وايضا زجهم الى
القضاء من اجل محاكمتهم
[موسيقى]
ان